bonjour bonjour à tout le monde je suis
fortement sur l'île je suis les
comédiens kirk être sera ce talent dans
la série gomorra et 6,6 pour saluer tous
les faons de gomorrhe sur canal+ et pour
bus saluer aussi pour répondre à des
questions qu'il y a eu pour moi et pour
salvatore
il doit répondre
tout de suite que nous heure nous n
avons pas eu des problèmes là et au
contraire nous avons rencontré et
allégeant de lampes led scampis aussi
une chaleur très fort pour nous parce
qu'ils sont bien contents que non nous
allons recompter des choses vraiment
fort et c'est très bien pour eux aussi
que le monde va savoir qu'est-ce qu'ils
passent là il est aussi d'aider des
histoires des petites histoires très
joli parce que tous les gens là il a
montré vraiment chaud l'air très fort
nous avons mal autres beaucoup de café
par exemple parce que tout le monde
quelque chose ils ont été vraiment
proche ah non
oui presque tous les comédiens de la
série et son ensemble ils sont tous des
monts bon comédien qui vient de là et la
majorité c'est de n'avoir fait
parce que je viens de théâtre j'avais
beaucoup de choses dans le théâtre j'ai
fait aussi du cinéma j'ai fait aussi de
la télévision de l'atv et je peux dire
vraiment que j'ai eu la grande chance de
travailler avec des maîtres pas
seulement italienne et qui m'ont donné
vraiment des choses incroyables pour mon
travail à pouvoir pour ce que je sais ce
que je fais maintenant
la première c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable pour moi parce que là c'est
changer complètement tout mon cas vieira
et je suis maintenant encore des
l'atmosphère de ces sensations que j'ai
eues sur l'a7 et c'était vraiment
quelque chose d'incroyable très fort
et il ya un autre au sud par la
souveraineté n'est pas mieux mais ils
m'ont dit que ça va être vraiment
quelque chose de très important seuil en
poupe
il va sortir
je pense prochains mois et ils m'ont dit
vraiment que c'est très très très bien
et je pense que vous déjà connaissez par
l'eau sur des talons
peut-être je sais pas pour moi moi non
je peux dire au monde parce que j'ai
essayé dans tous les interviews que
jules de raconter bien que nous sommes
des comédiens qui ne sont vraiment très
différent des carter contre la connerie
jouer et j'espère que aussi les
personnes que d'un avis sont très
proches des caractères que nous avons
joué fait comprendre qu'il y ait rien de
bien apprendre la caisse c'est un livre
qui va être donnée à la mort est encore
en ce lieu très fort à vous et merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup pour votre
chaleur et voilà on soit on attend le
bus